[موسيقى]
ينضم الليله من بيت لحم وراسل صباح
العربيه خالد القاسم خالد يسعد صباحك بيت
لحم في كامل زينتها احتفالا باجواء
الميلاد وعيد الميلاد انقل لنا الاجواء من
هناك تفضل
وعيد ميلاد مجيد لكما ولكل الزملاء خلف
الكواليس ولكل المشاهدين قناه العربيه
مدينه بيت لحم باتت ليله صاخبه يوم امس
من الفلسطينيين والسياح والحجيج الى هنا
الى ساحه كنيسه المهد للاحتفال باعياد
الميلاد
المجيد نحن ما تشاهدينه الان في الكاميرا
هي مدخل همم كنيسه المهد التي يتوافق
اليها الحجاج المسيحيين منذ اكثر من ثلاث
ساعات لاداء همم صلواتهم همم في اول يوم
في عيد بعد ليله اعياد همم الميلاد وهذه
الصلوات والاحتفالات ايضا تستمر لعده ايام
هنا في مدينه بيت لحم وتح اها في ساحه
كنيسه الماء
حابين انه نشوف شجره الميلاد اللي كل
الناس بتروح تتوافر لساحه المهد عشان
تشوفها ومن شير كمان للمشاهدين انه زياره
ساحه المعهد في فتره الميلاد اصبح تقليد
وعرف اجتماعي لكل الفلسطينيين يعني ليس
فقط مقتصر على المسيحيين منهم بل مسيحيون
ومسلمون يتوافدون الى ساحه المهد للاحتفال
بيوم الميلاد
من الشجره التي ترتفع قرابه ال20 متر في
ساحه كنيسه المهد كما ذكرت ان الدين عند
النظر همم في ليله عيد الميلاد الى ساحه
كنيسه المهد والتمعن في الحضور يختلط عليك
الامر هو عيد للمسلمين ام عيد للمسيحيين
ولكن بالنهايه هو عيد لكل العالم
الفلسطينيين يحضر الفلسطينيون من مختلف
الديانات ومن مختلف الاماكن همم
المشاركه في احتفالات اعياد همم الميلاد
من كل عام الى هنا الى ساحه كنيسه المهد
همم
وربما هي في القليل همم من دول العالم همم
بين المسجد
القيود المفروضه بسببرونا كيف تبدا الحركه
السياحيه توافد السياح له هناك
تحديدا ومن مشاهداتنا ومن بحثنا عن غرف
للمبيت في بيت لحم بصعوبه وجدنا غرفه لبيت
في مدينه بيت لحم وليست في هذه المنطقه
على اطراف
المدينه همم
مليئه بالسياح بحفلات السياح همم الاجانب
همم
الافارقه الامريكان ال- همم الفرنسيون من
بعض الدول العربيه مليئه همم بيت لحم ولكن
للاسف الشديد اليوم او غدا معظم هذه
الوفود تغادر همم الى دولها لا تقيم في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه فترات طويله ولكنها
تحضر لفتره وجيزه لاعياد الميلاد ثم تغادر
وبالنسبه لكرونا حقيقه لم نشاهد همم لا
هناك تعليمات رسميه بوضع
كمامه ولا هناك التزام من
المتواجدين في الساحات وفي الكنائس
بارتداء الكمامه او باتخاذ اساليب الحيطه
والحذر بعد اعوام من كورونا وبعد اعوام
منهم من التجمع والحضور الى هذا المكان
يعني الساعه 8:30
ما زال مبكرا رغم ذلك ارى من خلفك يعني
حركه للمره ولا السياح في محيط ساحه
المعهد واتمنى ان لا يكون هذا هو السبب
عبوسيك اليوم انه لسه الوقت مبكر مطلع
عينك لايف ما شفناها الابتسامه على الصبح
الدنيا عيد يا خالد
هذا لو في طنجره مقلوبه مع كوريا
ولكن
المنطقه هنا مكشوفه الرياح قويه لهذا هو
ربما سبب العبوس
العضلات الوجه ترفض ان
تتمددنا بوجودك معنا دائما الله يسامح
نادين خالد القاسم شكرا جزيلا شكرا لكم